knowing and having that presence of mind  to do what was the best tribute for Kobe  it's why most people are like oh man let  me just make a layup he's like let me go  into my memory bank of a Kobe dunk that  I could emulate as we're playing a live  game it just shows you his mind is  literally a computer the first day I got  traded here so I was like well remember  that time we beat y'all when you were at  the heat he goes y'all only beat us in  2011 and you had this many points and I  guarded you here it was crazy he was  like the only time it was because the  rotation was slow from the top of the  key and then I switched on you they  didn't score the rest of the game so I  said man get out of here